[Music]
that is Selena Gomez bringing joy to
some young people who definitely deserve
it
the singer surprised fans and a prom for
teens with cancer it's put on every year
by the Children's Hospital of Orange
County such a wonderful wonderful event
and here's mother wisely knees putting
smiles on the faces of all ages she and
Andy Samberg are back in Hotel
Transylvania 3 in the film based around
a bit of a family vacation a girl how do
you like the kind of distress you get
away from the know about home his wife
making an amazing meal watching Lord of
the Rings trilogy because children cozy
and I didn't know we were trying to win
like one okay so these two like to
compete but one thing they do agree on
making a family-friendly film is awesome
your daughter's almost won these movies
I'm sure with a blast for you to do I'm
glad to know that I have made at least
one thing she can watch for the ages
your little sister yeah just turn does
she recognize your voice yeah yeah well
she's my biggest supporter it's awesome
there is something about that woman I
don't trust selena is the voice of a
skeptical vampire on family vacay in the
movie when it comes to being a good
judge of character in real life she says
she's got that down - I'd like soon
but I I mean I come from a separated
family so I used to get very protective
over my parents and they would date how
are you in I can always
yes always a good time sitting down with
those two and I think the kids are gonna
like this movie everybody Hotel
Transylvania 3 summer vacation hits
theaters July 13
[Music]